we're back in Hollywood and et is here
to help us celebrate silly for five
seasons Paris Hilton and Nicole Richie
lived the simple life do you guys hang
out at Walmart they're people hanging
out at Walmart why the reality show took
the two party girls from the club to the
farm dropping them off in Altis Arkansas
for season one without money or cell
phones which it worth it are you a farm
girl girl now you know it was it was
right that I had a really really good
time I had the best time there and I
learned a lot I came back just viewing
everything so differently and look who
makes a cameo Parris's and Kyle Richards
before she became a real housewife she
was little scared about uh you know
obviously she's never been on the farm
but she was very excited but she was
also nervous she called me up and said
please FedEx some sweatpants and some
tennis shoes ASAP do they have FedEx in
Arkansas I'm not sure I didn't do it
definitely living in your room but I did
not think we'd be living on a porch with
the well the show became a rating smash
for Fox who put the girls on a
cross-country road trip for season two
in the first episode of the season Paris
gets thrown off of a horse and airlifted
to the hospital stepped on me too much
lemon the horse freaked out cuz all the
cameras right and I was not wearing
heels like it runs that
the wrong information we're not wearing
Stallone no it was wearing we were both
wearing masks in Kony this is not how I
wanted to wake up it was really gross
like it wasn't like a nudist colony with
people our age or anyone like hot I mean
they were really this is cute that could
be grounds for termination
what's termination fired and who can
forget their iconic catchphrase that's
hot
how did you come up with this seriously
or did you just roll out of your mouth
one day I've been saying it I was five
years old marry my sister a little like
that's hot and my mom would be like do
not say that
it just annoys people but then I just
kept saying it I'm just gonna ask you
about a couple of things you tell me
whether they're hot or not okay Kevin
Frazier oh here we go
for season three Paris and Nicole
traveled by Greyhound bus through the
Northeast it was so fun I mean it was a
lot different like the families were not
as polite I guess you would say because
they didn't have that southern
hospitality they were much different it
was like so different just being this
out and then being on the East Coast it
got nicer has further away from New York
they got like not as rude but like not
as aggressive but you know what it was
actually kind of refreshing because the
dirty jokes that I would say they would
have something to say back the Jupe
[Music]
this is sick the best is working in a
daycare center our children from six
weeks to five years old who are
underprivileged though we are I was just
like we were crying just like it was
really sad it was really nice to do that
for them your lips are very voluptuous
to your collagen yeah let's just not go
to school the worst was we were two
psychics that was fun that means like do
it till like 11 o'clock last night so we
were exhausted we're gonna die in two
years I couldn't even see the palms
anymore I was like blind it was like I
don't know what your problem says I told
everyone they were gonna die in two P
Diddy's party and just like special
events where we would just be like we're
leaving it's a reality show everyone
really didn't get to go after like the
first week season 3 also features a
cameo by Kesha before she was famous
Paris and Nicole helped Kesha's mom find
a date things took an unexpected turn in
2005 when Paris and Nicole got in a
fight and refused to film the show
together
Fox dropped the simple life but II
picked it up they hate each other's guts
and yet the show must go on
Paris introduced a new BFF in season 4 a
then-unknown Kim Kardashian who made two
appearances
[Music]
the girls made up in 2006 et caught them
on the dance floor together with Khloe
Kardashian at a party
for PlayStation 3 the series ended in
2007 after season 5 which sent Paris and
Nicole to camp love that do you love it
don't love what rumors of a reboot have
popped up over the years but it looks
like the girls have moved on
[Music]
that's the worst flag ring nicole has
her kwibi series Nicki fresh and Paris
is releasing a YouTube documentary
called this is Paris this year
everyone's used to sing on The Simple
Life and playing a character no one has
really seen how I really am in real life
because I've always been actually very
shy person so I've never showed myself
but with this film I really felt
comfortable to finally reveal who I
really am but thanks to Amazon Prime we
can binge Nicole in Paris's days of
living the simple life anytime
[Music]